hey everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i am very excited to
be playing a game that just came out
this week uh on playstation 5 and the
epic game store
this is godfall this video is sponsored
by gearbox who published the game
though it was developed by counter
player games so i'm basically going to
be diving into a bunch of the combat
here
uh having a good time okay let's let's
go fight people i guess
that's an interesting take on the roll
mechanic
it does a little swivel
i love it okay okay yes yes right stick
yes
hey buddy um yeah this is like a
looty rpg i believe does also have um
uh i'm distracted by the video game
three player
online co-op which is pretty neat and
you know whenever you hear the word
online you get worried about the micro
transactions but i will say
um they confirmed to me that this video
game does not have micro transactions
which i was very happy here always happy
to hear
i don't know what these green orbs are
but i it's health
it's health it's all disregard of course
it is
wouldn't she rather be smashing things
you'd love to see it
damn he got wrecked and then you got
wrecked the circle of life
what is this it's red is it gonna
explode
an interesting choice to make that not
explode
what did you say
this game is so stylish
all right try me
this feels like a fight it's about to
happen
or a cutscene that checks out too
so i understand you're trying to be
threatening
but i'm familiar with video games i
missed maybe this isn't gonna be that oh
maybe this isn't gonna be that easy oh
so you just own that circle now
well seems unfair you dopey sod
get out of the way
that seems seems good
seems like this could work for us and
that's why they call it godfall
all right
ooh there's xp now look at me playing a
video game
i level up i would like to know what
that means please
i didn't come here for your
encouragement sanctum
cool okay equipment menu
hurry a block to charge up your shield
when fully charged becomes primed for 40
seconds perry enemies all primed
like oh that's really cool um but for
now i think i can only upgrade these
ones
so oh i think i'm
actually gonna do this one because there
can be a lot of enemies on screen
and i feel like that will be handy for
me neat okay armory
i'm going to swap to the hammer
but let's just try out the hammer in
combat you know see
what happens
it's a lot slower
oh that that's as cool as hell cinematic
though
oh yeah i can use my new my new thingy
um lb uh
lbnb
i like it who are you common jewel
blades
i bet he's gonna be real fast oh yes yes
yes yes yes yes good
oh sorry did i ruin the party oh that's
my bad
dude the middle got wrecked
and what are you about what are you what
are you up to
big guy you been
you being a coward slap me on my own
face
okay
it's the bluest thing i've ever seen
is this gonna be a boss fight
oh maybe fight is what it feels like
perilous attack
parry perilous attack to stun an enemy
for duration
oh but i can't block it oh that's
interesting
okay
well that's a lot oh my gosh
oh my gosh okay i just don't feel like
i'm ready for this yet you know
nope no no i know this game was also
supposed to have like a very
robust end game where uh
oh neat the enemies actually
could have done more damage here i guess
um
scale to how good you get and i wonder
if that is like
boss fight heavy nope nope nope that
seems bad why what are you why you why
are you in the sky
who told you you could do that i don't
like that you're lighting everything on
fire
i just i don't i don't like it
i i feel i feel very stuck [ __ ] oh no
but maybe this is good news maybe he's
lighting everything on fire
as a panic because i am getting him so
good
see i feel good about that i think that
was a good parry and then i let him on
fire maybe
come on buddy die die just die what if
you just died
right now didn't block that successfully
i'm on fire again
come on yeah i think i did it
it's very very smooth
you just steal that man's like entire
face
and absorb it okay
valor plates huh each valve plate
provides a unique passive trait arch on
fury and augment constellation switch
between valve plates and the sanctum
between missions
oh and i craft these i mean yeah let's
do it
from my understanding these are mostly
aesthetic but do give you different like
passive abilities
oh and my webcam's gone great love that
for us okay
so because i would like this queen
that's me right now i like the teal
oh i'm just a sucker for
ridiculous fantasy gob you know it's
like a peacock
um all right i would like to unlock one
more valor plate so we'll we'll play a
level and like
see how phoenix plays um check that out
and then see if i can actually unlock
one more
for you guys let's do it
that was a good parry good work self
and we soul shattered him i think
just gonna do that to you sometimes you
know
overkill just makes you feel good about
yourself is all i'm saying
a chest we have a new weapon
and it is called prickl
what is this
all right you big jerk
can't dodge that punk
oh that's the one i gotta block yeah did
it did it did it did it did it
oh my god and i miss what a waste
goddamn what what what
hey bud my archon fury's ready though
so let's boom right
i think it gives me extra fire damage
and i look cool as hell
oh that was a good dodge alana
how about that how about that oh kicking
your butt dude
oh i shouldn't dodge that one oh no okay
well come on go for it go for it go for
it nope
that's unblockable and you're dead
and you're about to be dead and you're
dead and you're gonna be dead
oh i beat him with his own hammer all
right well
maybe next time but maybe next time ah
a little stuff he dropped oh my gosh
no i didn't even realize that was part
of the many
okay i guess these are just like
unlockables but
oh my gosh this is
uh what yes
okay okay
excellent
you'd love to see it okay cool well i
already love this thing so how can i
upgrade it
yes i do like that but no i'm just gonna
get better
the other stuff's just gonna get better
so except for that purple amulet
which we already took off i'm gonna
upgrade this twice if i'm being honest
all right you guys i did some searching
and i have
60 infused jasper
which means i can get this absolute
champion
grey hawk who is very much my style
or your boy bulwark um
who can summon three physical sentinels
which sounds really cool i think that i
want to go with
with misa over here maybe
like the shockwave sounds rad so i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it
i'm doing it yes
the armor of individuality is favored by
those who yes
to forge their own path oh my gosh
oh my gosh and then we will go
and fight some people and check out the
shockwave is the plan
okay we got it we got it we got it
very cool
all right i think i just got a skill
point i did i kind of want to upgrade
this oh that's just more damage though
during the time you're going to press rt
yes we got that
lt and b in their performance yes yes
i will have it
wonderful wonderful stuff um i think
that's it for this video everyone
obviously i will leave a link in the
description below to where you can check
out the game if you are interested like
i said it is on
ps5 and on the epic game store i am
playing on pc myself
uh huge thanks to gearbox for sponsoring
this video and i will see you all next
time
sorry about my webcam bye